we're going to do MOBA we don't just
want to clone we knew we were coming
together nowhere and we knew that the
people who like MOBAs work super die
hard we put it in the players hands at a
very early stage and we were just kind
of like we're gonna build this in front
of you guys and whatever you tell us
about this we are going to hear whether
we like it or not it's just a constant
dialogue with our players and dog gate
is constantly getting better for it
Mobile stands for multi-user online
battle arena for Don game well we dunce
broken down the genre to its component
parts and built a new game that doesn't
just clone the classic MOBA but builds
on it by focusing on a flexible meta
game but the metagame and Dawn gate is
based around your particular team
composition the rules your team is
choosing so the game is gonna play
different every single time allows you
and your team to genuinely try new
strategies it allows them to basically
play any of these characters that they
really identify with in any position in
the game when we set out to mcdon gate
really what we wanted was characters who
are fighting for a purpose all of the
characters that you play the map that
you're playing on has been conceived of
in a massive epic story arc that's
really just kicking off with the players
salas he's a character who I love to
play is sort of a lizard mug very zen
there is a little spirit whisk dude I
love this design of that guy big guys
who acts as an armor and skulls I like
that a lot so I like supports one
hundred percent the best I like making
support same plane supports the best I
really like that we have a whole section
of the world that's devoted to badass
bookish nerds I like books dude if you
can't geek out about something I'm
probably not gonna have a good time
hanging up we built this team
specifically to make this game to make
dawngate we're a group of hardcore modal
players so we knew if we're gonna make
something awesome for our players had to
be awesome for us
the sky is really the limit song it has
been designed to entertain you the
opportunity is there for us to go
wherever we want so long as it makes
sense for the player